Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David Pakman.
This is actually really, really funny. Last
week during live calls, someone called and
they had some kind of power tool going in the
background. And I asked if they were running
a lathe. The eggman actually called. And I think
the Egemen works in some kind of a machine shop.
He called and actually played the sound
of a lathe for me. Really great work,
AGYEMAN Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, this
could be a bandsaw. I don't know.
Speaker 1:
Yeah, it went on for, like a full
two minutes, if you can believe it.
And then, like, another minute later,
does he sign off, let's
Speaker 2: say, you
Speaker 1:
know, it just cuts off. OK, all right. Thank you,
AGYEMAN. Very clever. The comedic stylings of the
AGYEMAN, please. If you are using a bandsaw
or God forbid, a leaf blower, how are leaf
blower gas powered leaf blowers even legal?
You don't know how many episodes of this show
have been ruined by leaf blowers. Anyway, please
don't call in if that's what you're doing.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
The FBI has released the first 911 document
after an order from Joe Biden. What is in this
document much anticipated? What is in it? Also,
more and more Democrats are accepting
or even touting the label progressive.
I don't think they're particularly progressive,
but it still raises an interesting question.
Is it now politically advantageous to label
yourself progressive if you're in the Democratic
Party? And then number three on today's Bonas
show, restaurants in many parts of the country
are closing down indoor dining rooms again. Are we
heading for a winter in the parts of the country
that have winter with no indoor dining? Once
again, all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. Join me by signing up at Join Pakman
dot com. You'll get instant access to the bonus
show. You can also get access via Patreon if
you prefer. Go to Patreus dotcom slash The
David Pakman Show. What a tremendous bonus
Unidentified: we have for you today.